does this stay for with no five five or
six no I've only had like three or three
nights with him I think anyway I am
gonna be leaving him for the first time
I'm leaving the house and leaving him
here with Jenna
taking care of him teach him all of his
good things he's really really demanding
like I wear a size 7 and a half shoe I
don't think you guys understand how
little he is he is so teeny teeny tiny
always shaking
he'd go care of my baby say hello to
wireless charging
[Music]
so here's the power mat you just plug it
in set it down didn't charge us here's
the proof
charging
we're good and Starbucks I'll be filling
myself and they started asking me about
the power Matt I don't know if they
thought that like I worked for them I
was like no no here this is how works of
leaving Starbucks power Matt demos
that's the first time I saw that they
had the new adaptors because they only
have the old iPad and iPhone charger so
they now have micro USB and the
lightning cable so that's pretty neat
something have to look into it maybe
it'll be a tech Tuesday maybe I can tell
power Matt to send me some and I gonna
have a couple extras to give to you guys
it's neat I'm real into it okay I gotta
go I got a drive I'm late guys how's it
going
so my allergies are bothering me a
little bit today so don't mind this hot
mess I'm gonna see if I can put Maddie
in side of this little Lego container
you sleep in though I just gave him a
bath so I'm not bathing him everyday but
you've got the please so we gotta go
there's some things let's see if you can
fit in this little box it's okay you can
I can't believe it
look at your cuteness your inquisitive
nature this is called laundry right here
good boy we're learning so much we're so
smart gonna get lessons given we can fit
in here good have Maddy end things you
don't like it video
[Music]
[Applause]
ready for a car ride mm-hmm you're so
tired all you do is sleep sleep sleep no
matter what got sleeping on your mind
and you never give it up put your paws
in the air everybody see you all right
do you have a potty
that means potty well I gotta go pick up
this drone because it's gonna be time to
learn how to fly it
so how's he doing in there our first car
ride so this is a sleepy pod you can
just strap him in pups first trip to the
camera store
I'm sure he's real excited about it
here we go bud it's our first trip to
the store look at you bud Matt we
haven't fun at your first trip to the to
Sammy's no we gotta get a drone bud what
do you think you're doing no Pig Oh God
first one I don't know he sees a couple
times
[Music]
you've got so many friends now I think
he's sleeping with his eyes open wait
that one oh no don't worry okay wait you
got to tell me how to do this first okay
so we just figured something out we've
been complaining about this I keep
calling the mana Rovers put them on
whatever this thing is they're it's
there's a beginner mode guys hi there's
a beginner mode no I didn't do it yet is
it different than Carlos's you max is
really quick do you have you know your
honors here rulers in the trunk real
girls in the truck look at you guys just
working hard in the office poor Matt's
was hard he did a 24 hour livestream oh
my gosh you're dedicated I'm impressed
so what did you say to do again yeah
well the B button for three seconds
should I get off of this it's one foot
love say that every time one foot back
okay oh that's an unlock button think is
this who's red you know what that means
no it's danger road that's right really
all right well thanks for watching guys
I think this might be a combination of
two different days in this vlog I'm not
really sure I've lost track I still have
some videos that I haven't posted so I'm
a little behind you know really would
you expect anything else from my channel
it's always a mess but Maddie is doing
so much better he had a really good day
today yesterday he wasn't feeling so
well pretty much since I brought him
home he's sort of just been getting
adjusted and getting his his bearings
but he's having some solid poos he's
learning he hasn't actually quite nailed
the tap the bell to go potty yet but
he's on his way he's on his way so I'll
see you guys tomorrow in whatever video
I happened to post next see you guys
later
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'm dying